مستمرون معكم مشاهدينا في تغطيتنا لتطورات
الاوضاع في السودان مع استمرار المواجهات
المسلحه بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع لليوم الثاني على التوالي مندوب
السودان في الجامعه العربيه قال قبل قليل
بان القوات المسلحه تمكنت من السيطره على
الاوضاع فيما قال مسؤول في الجيش السوداني
ان المعارك قد تستغرق عده ايام فيما تتجه
الانظار الى محيط مقر قياده الجيش
بالعاصمه الخرطوم حيث تدور المواجهات
الاكثر شراسه حاليا ياتي ذلك فيما اعلنت
لجنه اطباء السودان ارتفاع حصيله القتلى
الى سته وخمسين شخصا والمصابين الى نحو
600 فيما دعت لجنه الاطباء الى تغليب صوت
العقل وفتحي ممرات امنه لاجلاء المحتاجزين
والعالقين والمصابين
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اذا نتابع واياكم مشاهدينا هذا الفيديو
وهو طبعا الفيديو المتداول في الصفحات
مقربه
للجيش السوداني نشرت هذا الفيديو فيديو
للسيطره على معسكر كرري التابع لقوات
الدعم السريع في ام درمان اذا الجيش
السوداني ينشر مقطعا
لقوته عبر صفحات
مقربه طبعا للجيش السوداني مقطع مصور
للقوات قوات الجيش السوداني داخل معسكر
كرري اكبر قاعده للدعم السريع في ام درمان
الجيش السوداني كان قد اعلن السيطره على
عدد من المراكز والمقرات التابعه لقوات
الدعم السريع في اكثر من ولايه
وهذا المعسكر معسكر كرري اذا
هو المعسكر اذا
المعسكر الذي تمت السيطره عليه في هذا
الفيديو من قبل الجيش السوداني نستمع ثم
نعود اكبر الله اكبر
استلامه
وافكر كرري قدام السريع
عرباتهم ومدرعاتهم
مبروك
الله اكبر
[موسيقى]
اذا تتواصلوا الاشتباكات في محيط القياده
العامه للجيش بالعاصمه الخرطوم ويقع مقر
القياده العامه في المنطقه الشماليه من
العاصمه على بعد نحو اربعه كيلو مترات فقط
من مطار الخرطوم كما انه يعد مركزا مهما
وحساسا بالنسبه لقوات الجيش السوداني
ويستمر اطلاق الرصاص في محيط المبنى مع
تداول اخبار عن استخدام اسلحه ثقيله هذا
وثقت مشاهد من العاصمه الخرطوم تصاعد
اعمده الدخان في سماء الخرطوم وذوي
المدافع واطلاق الرصاص نشاهد
[موسيقى]
اعلن الجيش السوداني سيطرته على قواعد
ومقرات قوات الدعم السريع في سبع ولايات
وقال الجيش في بيانه ان عناصره سيطرت على
مقرات الدعم السريع في بورتسودان وكسلا
والغضارف والدمازين وكوسي وكادوقلي وكذلك
معسكر كرري شمال ام درمان مضيفا ان افراد
قوات الدعم فروا من تلك المواقع تاركنا كل
عتادهم
وينضم الينا من الخرطوم مراسل العربيه
سالم الهاشمي سالم مساء الخير مرحبا بك
معي في هذه التغطيه الاوضاع في العاصمه
الخرطوم كيف تبدو حتى هذه اللحظه قبل قليل
الحديث عن غارات جويه على مقر للدعم
السريع في شرق الخرطوم
ما زالت هذه الغارات متواصله وما زالت
ايضا كذلك تبادل اطلاق النار الكثيف
والقنابل وصوت الرصاص يسمع من الفين
والاخرى الان في الخرطوم في وسط الخرطوم
نستمع الى الاشتباكات التي هي في القياده
العامه للجيش وكذلك هناك اشتباكات في
الشوارع الاخرى مثل شارع المطار وحتى في
شارع الصحافه هذه الشوارع انا ايضا تدور
فيها معارك الدعم السريع والجيش هذا ياتي
بتزامن مع هذه
الحمله هو الحمله المكثفه للطيران للجيش
السوداني التي قال الجيش السوداني انه
سيشنها على مواقع قوات الدعم السريع
طيب السؤال ايضا عن المراكز التي سيطرت
عليها قوات الجيش المركز التابعه
للدعم السريع هل هناك تقديرات حتى هذه
اللحظه تتحدثون عن العاصمه الخرطوم فقط
نعم انا كنت قادم مكتب
هذه الشوارع بالكامل تنتشر فيها قوات
الدعم السريعه الان في شارع عباد خاتم
تنتشر هذه القوات اي شرق المطار وحتى
الجهه الجنوبيه للمطار وحتى الجهه الغربيه
للمطار كل هذه الامتدادات توجد بها عربات
وعربات دفع رباعي وكذلك
المدرعات الصغيره
للقوات الدعم السريع وهي منتشره بكثافه في
هذه المناطق
بهذا الامر يفهم ان ايضا بالقدر الذي هناك
انتشار فيه وحديث الجيش عن
عن انتشاره وعن سيطرته هناك بعض المناطق
ما زالت تحت بسيطه التي يرى الجيش
السودانيه انها قوات متمرده
يعني نتحدث عن انتشار كثيف لقوات الدعم
السريع بشكل
مكثف في العاصمه الخرطوم حتى هذه
اللحظه فيما يخص ايضا حتى خدمات الانترنت
في العاصمه الخرطوم التيار الكهربائي ايضا
الانقطاع من عدمه كيف يمكن الحديث عنها
سالم
نعم التيار الكهربائي قطع من الباليه في
المناطق كثيره جدا لعاصمه كذلك الامداد
المائي كذلك في مناطق عده المناطق قليله
جدا هي التي تنعمل بسياره الكهربائي وكذلك
في ولايه الخرطوم بقيه المناطق
انقطاعتها لهذه الخدمتين خدمه الانترنت
متذبذبه هناك شبكه
قطع منها الاتصال والانترنت كذا الشبكات
غير ثابته
فقط دعنا نستمع لهذه الاصوات اصوات اطلاق
النار في العاصمه الخرطوم
سالم نعود لك مره اخرى صوره منذ يعني صباح
اليوم هي حول محيط مقر قياده الجيش
السوداني سماع لذوي اطلاق نار كثيف منذ
الصباح حول هذه المنطقه ما هو التقييم في
هذه المنطقه الاشتباكات اين تدور تحديدا
بنعمل الاشتباكات الان تدور في محيط
القياده العامه للجيش الذي خانه الدعم
السريع ويسيطر عليها
والجيش السوداني ذكر بان الدعم السريع لا
يسيطر على القياده العامه على الاطلاق
هناك جيوب فقط بسيطه جدا
لان هذا الامر
[موسيقى]
ربما يطول عملك
وينشر التوتر والمواطنين
ايضا ما الذي جاء في بيانها ويمكن تلخيصه
سالم
[موسيقى]
والحريه والتغيير تحدثت صوت العقل ونادت
كل الاغراض
تستعد او تقدم استعدادا واضحا بان تتنازل
ولو قليلا
بمثل هذه
التصرفات لان هذا هذه المعركه ليس فيها
رابح والك
ل السودان
شكرا جزيلا لك سالم على كل هذه المعلومات
سنحاول العوده لك مره اخرى نتركك فقط لبعض
الوقت حتى تجمع بعض المعلومات اذا
مشاهدينا هذه صور مباشره كما ذكرنا ترصدها
العربيه بشكل خاص للمشهد من محيط مقر
القياده العامه للقوات المسلحه السودانيه
بالعاصمه الخرطوم سماع لذوي اطلاق النار
والرشاقات
الرصاص لا تتوقف منذ صباح اليوم وحتى ليله
البارحه لكن باصوات الرصاص تكثفت منذ صباح
هذا اليوم واعمده الدخان يعني تتصاعد بشكل
كبير شكل مستمر ايضا في هذه الصوره التي
نتابعها واياكم الان على شاشه العربيه اذا
مشاهدينا في المواقف السياسيه حضرت قوى
الحريه والتغيير من استمرار المواجهات بين
قوات الجيش والدعم السريع وسقوط ضحايا قوى
الحريه والتغيير دعت قيادات الجيش والدعم
السريع الى تحكيم صوت العقل والى وقف
المواجهات كما اتهمت الحريه والتغيير حلول
النظام السابق بالتعبئه للحرب في البلاد
مشدده على ضروره نبذ خطاب الكراهيه وتاجيج
الحرب ومعالجه الخلافات عبر الحلول
السياسيه
هذا ونشر الجيش السوداني فيديو لاستيلائه
على اكثر من 50 عربه وسياره للدعم السريع
في منطقه الدمازين بولايه للازرق
الله
اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الفرقه الرابعه تمازين الفرقه الرابعه
نستلم عدد 35 عربه
عربه سحاب اثنين عربه
واحد عربه تنكر ماء وكميه من الزهايا الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
ومن الخرطوم ينضموا الينا عدل السيد احمد
الكاتب الصحفي سيد عادل مرحبا بك معي في
هذه التغطيه دعني ابدا اولا مما ذكره
السفير السوداني في اجتماع مندوبي الجامعه
العربيه قال بان ما يجري في السودان هو
شان داخلي ونعمل على حله بانفسنا برايك هل
هذا ممكن
[موسيقى]
يجب ان نتعرض لمسالتين المساله الاولى انه
العمليه هذه هي يعني
الامر عمليه عسكريه بحته يعني انا لا اميل
كثيرا
للتحليل القائل بانها اشبه بالديناريو
الليبي او السيناري والسوري او السيناريو
اليمني هذا هو سيناريو السوداني من الدرجه
الاولى
خاصه ان هناك تجارب كثيره جدا تدل على ان
القوات المسلحه السودانيه منذ انشائها عام
ومواجهتها لاول تمرد عام 1955
قامت هذه القوات على اساس مهني وعلى اساس
قومي تم انشاء وفق هياكل ووفق كفاءات وفي
قانون لذلك من ناحيه فنيه يمكن توثيق ما
يحدث الان بانه عمليه عسكريه ليس له اي
ابعاد اسميه او ابعاد قبليه او ابعاد
دينيه او خلافه هذا من ناحيه فنيه بحته
اقول انا كمراقب
يعني متواجد في قلب الخرطوم الامر الثاني
انا اعتقد انه لا بد من
نتحدث عن ضروره الجلوس على مائده للتفاوض
بالطبع فان اي عمليه عسكريه مهما يعني
كانت كبيره او صغيره
فان صوت الحوار يجب ان يسود انا الان
اعتقد انه انا الاوان كي نقول بان ما يحدث
هو عمليه عسكريه بحته
بطبيعه الحال ان اردت ان تتعرف على
التوصيف الدقيق بانه عمليه بحثه يجب ان
نتطرق الى انه لا يوجد اصلا توازن هو هذا
جيش جيش متكامل باجهزه مهنيه عاليه جدا
بامكانيات تقوم على سلاح المشاه وعلى سلاح
الطيران وعلى سلاح المدرعات فلذلك
المساله بالنسبه للجيش عمليه لا يوجد
تواجده هو لذلك كل ما يرشح من معلومات حول
ان القوات المسلحه تستولي على عربات او
على مواقف الدعم السريع انا اعتقد انها
اخبار صحيحه ومؤكده لان الجنس لو امكانيات
كبيره جدا
سيد عادل
طيب يبدو ان فقدنا الاتصال
بالسيد عادل
السيد احمد الكاتب الصحه في سنحاول العوده
اليه مره اخرى اذا الان نتابع هذه الاخبار
العاجله اسفل الشاشه نقلا عن الرئاسه
المصريه
السيسي
نداء للوقف الفوري لاطلاق النار في
السودان اذا مصر وجنوب السودان تعربان عن
استعدادهما للقيام بدور الوساطه بين طرفي
الصراع
بالسودان اذا الرئاسه المصريه تقول بان
الرئيس عبد الفتاح السيسي
رئيس جنوب السوداني والجهال نداءا للوقف
الفوري لاطلاق النار في السودان
وطبعا تاتي هذه الدعوات مع استمرار هذا
الاشتباك منذ صباح اليوم واصوات اطلاق
الرصاص والدوي المدافع حول القياده
العملي الجيش السوداني مقر القياده في
العاصمه الخرطوم تصاعد اعمده الدخان وتاتي
الدعوه من الرئاسه المصريه
تحديدا الرئيس عبد الفتاح السيسي
والسلفاكير ايضا من جانب جنوب السودان
اللذاني وجهاني داء للوقف الفوري لاطلاق
النار في السودان مراسل العربيه قبل قليل
نقل بان قوات الدعم السريع تنتشر بشكل
مكثف في شارع المطار بالعاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم
ايضا لا زلزلنا نتابع واياكم هذه الصوره
مشاهدينا لليوم الثاني على التوالي اليوم
الثاني على التوالي من هذه الاشتباكات بين
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع نتابع
هذا الفيديو ايضا هذا الفيديو من محيط
القياده العامه للجيش
السوداني كما نتابع في هذه الصور
المتداوله اذا على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي
سنتابع بشكل ادق ربما احد الجنود هنا يشرح
في هذا الفيديو نحاول ان نستمع عليه الصوت
الطبيعي
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر
اذا نعيد التذكير بهذه المشاهد
وهذا الفيديو
للاشتباكات في محيط القياده العامه للجيش
السوداني قبل قليل هذه الصور ايضا ربما
للقذائف التي استخدمت في هذه
الاشتباكات وهي ملقات على قارعه الطريق
المؤدي الى القياده العامه للجيش السوداني
نستمع
[موسيقى]
مباشره الى مدينه مروي انضم الينا من هناك
مراسله للعربيه نزار بقداوي نزار مرحبا بك
معي ماذا لديك من جديد في مروي حتى اللحظه
ان كان من تحديثات
الوضع كالتالي كما اشرنا
مسبقا حاله التطويق التي تفرض من قبل قوات
الجيش السوداني على مطار مروي الدولي الذي
تلحق به قاعده مروي العسكريه الجويه حاله
التطبيق ما زالت مستمره المعلومات عن وصول
امدادات للجيش
بدات الان ترد الى الاسافير بان هناك قوات
ربما قد تصل الى هذه المنطقه ايضا هنالك
معلومات بان قوات الدعم السريع ايضا يمكن
ان تصل الى هذه المنطقه في اي لحظه لتشكل
سندا ودعما للقوات هذه معلومات اوليه لم
نستطيع ان نتاكد منها 100% لكنها بدات ترد
تسريبات المعطى الاخر بان حاله الترقب
الان هي العنوان الاكبر والعنوان الذي
يسود هنا في مدينه مروي لان قوات الدعم
السريع ما زالت تتمركز داخل القاعده
العسكريه المطار وقوات الجيش ما زالت تطوق
هذا المكان هذا يعني شيء واحد بانه في اي
لحظه يمكن ان تنفجر الاوضاع اما ان تسلم
قوات الدعم السريعه الياتها وعتادها
واسلحتها واما ان تدخل في اشتباكات مسلحه
مع الجيش السوداني واما ان يتدخل الطيران
الحربي لحسم هذه الوضعيه الامنيه
ام لا التدخل في في مناطق
التدخل حسب المسحه الجوي الذي
بدا في الاولى
من اليوم
شمل
[موسيقى]
تصبح قاعده مروي هي امتداد او تصبح
المدينه هي امتداد لعمليه عسكريه بغات من
المطار انتقلت الى ارجاء المدينه هم يرجون
ويتمنون ويدعون الله تصل الامور الى هذه
المرحله وان تحقن الدماء وان يسقط صوت
الرصاص في هذه المدينه التي تعرض بانها
مروي الامنه مروي الوادعه هكذا يطلق اهلها
عليها دائما ونحن نتمنى ذلك لكن السؤال
ايضا كذلك عن الاهالي ومواطنين هذه
المدينه هل هناك من خرج من هذه المدينه
هناك حاله هلع بين المواطنين دفعتهم
للخروج لان الزوح الى مناطق اخرى قريبه من
مروي نزار
نعم هنالك من انتقل من منطقه الى منطقه
ولكن لا يمكن لنا ان نطلق عليها عمليه
نزوح باعتبار ان النزوح هو بنسبه معينه
يمكن ان نطلق على هذه الموجه نزوح لكن من
انتقل هم اسر تخوفوا من امكانيه ان تمتد
النيران اذا ما حدثت مساء الامس ولكنها لم
تحدث الى منازلهم الى مواقعهم هذا لم
يحدثوا وبطبيعه الحال ربما عادوا صباح هذا
اليوم الى مناطقهم او عادوا الى المناطق
الامنه لكن الان المدينه مستقره المدينه
الان مطمئنه لا وجود لحشود عسكريه كما
ذكرنا سابقا في مدخلات سابقه لا وجود
لعتاد عسكري او دبابات او اليات للدفع
الرباعي هنا في المدينه
وجود العساكر او وجود قوات الجيش في
المناطق المفترض ان تكون فيها امام
المستشفى العسكري وامام المناطق الاخرى
تتمركز في مناطق استراتيجيه حتى الجسر
الرئيس الذي يربط بين مدينه مروي وبين
بقيه اجزاء المدينه او الولايه هو مفتوح
وبقرب من هذه المدينه مدينه مروي لا يبتعد
كثيرا
مروي او خزام مروي الموجود على نهر النيل
ايضا الوضعيه امنه في تلك المنطقه لكن
مسرح العمليات الرئيس يظل حتى اللحظه في
الجزئيه المتعلقه بمطار مروي الدولي
وبالقاعده العسكريه الملحقه بهذا المطار
هل هناك من توقعات بوصول تعزيزات عسكريه
للجيش السوداني باتجاه مروي لتعزيز اغلاق
القاعده العسكريه والمخارج هذه القاعده
العسكريه والمطار التابع لها
هذه الامور كلها متوقعه في اي لحظه يمكن
ان تصل هذه القوات في اي لحظه ايضا يمكن
ان تصل قوات اخرى لقوات الدعم السريع في
اي لحظه يمكن ان يتدخل الطيران كل هذه
الفرضيات الان مطروحه هي الان حرب مفتوحه
كما قال الجيش هي حرب قد تمتد لايام تتنوع
فيها الاساليب تتنوع فيها القطط العسكريه
تتنوع فيها التكتيكات والتدخلات والخروج
والعبور هي حرب بمعنى الكلمه الان شوارع
الخرطوم
محاصره بالسلاح هنا في مروي الاوضاع كانت
مشتعله بالتالي نتوقع في كل لحظه ان تتغير
المعطيات من شيء الى اخر اشكرك جزيل الشكر
على كل هذه المعلومات والتفاصيل سنعود
اليك حاله ما جده جديد في مروي مراسل
العربيه نزار بقداوي
الجيش السوداني وقوه الدعم السريع التاسيس
الجيش السوداني تاسس في عام
1925 قوات الدعم السريع تاسست في اغسطس
2013 التعداد العسكري الجيش السوداني يبلغ
قوات الدعم تقدر بنحو
العسكريه الجويه الجيش السوداني لديه 191
طائره حربيه
45 مقاتله 37 طائره هجوميه وخمس وعشرون
طائره شحن عسكريه قوه الدعم لا تمتلك اي
طائرات
الترسانه العسكريه البريه الجيش السوداني
يمتلك 20 منصه صواريخ
170 دبابه
403 مدرعات سبعه الاف مركبه عسكريه قوه
الدعم لديها اسلحه خفيفه ومتوسطه
10,000 سياره رباعيه الدفع الجيش السوداني
يحتل المرتبه 75 عالميا في قائمه اقوى
جيوش العالم
[موسيقى]
القاهره تنضم الينا اسماء الحسين مدير
التحرير صحيفه الاهرام والمختصه كذلك ايضا
في الشؤون الافريقيه سيدي اسماء مرحبا بك
معي في هذه التغطيه قبل قليل مصر وجنوب
افريقيا دعوا كما تابعتي معنا في الاخبار
العاجله نداء
للوقف الفوري لاطلاق النار في السودان كيف
يمكن ان تنعكس هذه الدعوه في السودان هل
يمكن ان تلقى صدى
اهلا وسهلا استاذ نايف التحيه لك ولكل
الساده المشاهدين الكرام يعني
يعني مشاهد حزينه للغايه تنقلها شاشه
العربيه عن الوضع في الخرطوم وفي السودان
ويبدو ان ما خفي كان اعظم وان الوضع شديد
الماساويه شديد الكارثيه
وضع كابوسي لم يكن يخطر على بال اي سوداني
في يوم من الايام ان يرى الامور تصل الى
هذا الحد في بلده هذا وضع غير مسبوق
وبالتالي تحرك الدول الشقيقه وصديقه من
اجل انقاذ هذا الوضع والدعوه لوقف اطلاق
دعوه الاطراف لوقف فوري لاطلاق النار هو
امر مهم
واعتقد انه مصر والسودان لهم خصوصيه في
علاقتهم بالسودان
ومصر علاقتها معروفه بالسودان وكذلك جنوب
السودان الذي كان حتى فتره قريبه جدا حتى
عام 2011 جزء من السودان الكبير الموحد
وبعد ذلك اصبحت بعض الثوره السودانيه
علاقات وثيقه بين الجانبين
وجنوب السودان هي راعت اتفاقيه السلام
جوبا
ويتمتعان بعلاقات طيبه الان
مصر وجنوب السودان يعني هم اعربوا عن
الاستعداد للقيام بدور
الوساطه بين طرفي الصراع بالسودان اسال
هنا عن محددات وشكل هذه الوساطه كيف يمكن
ان تقدم لاطراف الصراع العسكريه في هذا
الوضع الحالي وضع الاشتباكات واحتدام
المعارك في الارض
نعم بالفعل نحن ازاء وضع معقد شديد
التعقيد امام طرفين
بمواقفهم الحديه كل منهم يرى ان المعادله
صفريه
بنفي الطرف الاخر او اقصائي او ابعاده من
المشهد تماما وبالتالي هناك صعوبه جدا في
التعامل مع مثل هذه المواقف الحديه والامر
يتطلب ان تكون الوساطه المرتقبه هي وساطه
فعاله وساطه تتحرك سريعا وساط لديها ايضا
قدره على التاثير والضغط على الطرفين
اللذين لا يستمعان الان الا لصوت البنادق
والمدافع التي يطلقونها والقذائف وغيرها
وبالتالي هناك حاجه لان تتعزز اي وساطه
مقبله بشان السودان باكبر قدر من القوى
المؤثره على الصعيد الاقليمي والدولي حتى
يكتب لها الفاعليه والقدره على على
الطرفين العنيدين اللذين لن ينصتان
للنداءات والمناشدات والرجاءات وانما
سينسطوا حاله وجود ضغوط
يعني
تهديدات بعقوبات ان لم يرتدع الطرف
المعتدي عن الكف عن عدوانه وبالتالي هناك
حاجه لان تكون هناك وساطه قويه بشان هذه
الاوساط الاوضاع المعقده
ايضا كذلك اعلن بانه سيعقد جلسه طارئه
اليوم للبحث في
الملف السوداني ما النتائج المتوقعه برايك
نعم
مجلس السلم والامن الافريقي مجلس الامن
الدولي الجامعه العربيه كل هذه الاطراف
تتحرك وجاي التحركها لانه السودان بلد مهم
جدا بالنسبه
لامته العربيه بالنسبه لقارته الافريقيه
بالنسبه للعالم وموقعه الجيش الاستراتيجي
المهم وبالتالي كل هذه التحركات هي
التحركات تعبر عن نوايا طيبه تعبر عن
احساس وادراك بخطوره الموقف
وتداعياته السلبيه الهائله التي لم تتوقف
عند حدود السودان وانما ستتعداها الى كل
دول جواره افريقيا وعربيه والى مصالح
دوليه في هذه المنطقه من العالم ولكن
اعتقد ان كل هذه الجهود يجب ان تتوحد
بطريقه ما لانه تعدد المبادرات احيانا
يتيح الفرصه للاطراف المتنازعه للتنقل بين
المبادرات والقفز
هذه المبادرات وقبول هذه ورفض تلك وتضييع
الوقت اعتقد اننا بحاجه الى جهود موحده
عربيه افريقيه دوليه من اجل حل هذه الازمه
المستعصيه التي لا ينبغي ان تترك همم
لتمتد اكثر من ذلك لانه سيكون لها عواقب
وخيمه على الجميع وهو السؤال هنا نعم صحيح
عن العواقب العواقب
بالنسبه للسودان والعواقب ايضا حتى
الاقليميه التي قد تخلفها هذه الازمه كيف
يمكنني
عواقب كلنا راينا في السودان يعني تاثيرات
هائله على سكان المدنيين ما اعلن عنه من
56 قتيل هذا عدد ضئيل جدا ولجنه الاطباء
قالت انه لا يعبر عن العشرات من الضحايا
من العسكريين من الجانبين
يعني المئات المصابين وحالات حرجه يعني
فعلا الاوضاع لم يكشف النقاب عن كل كارثيه
الاوضاع بالنسبه للاقليم ستتكون هناك
تداعيات هائله للغايه على كل المنطقه
على منطقه البحر الاحمر على المنطقه على
الدول العربيه المشاطئه للسودان لقباله
البحر الاحمر على مصر ايجارتها الشماليه
يعني حتى الان نحن وحتى بدون هذه الاحداث
هناك تدفقات بشريه هائله هجره جماعيه من
السودانيين على مدى العامين الماضيين الى
مصر باعداد كبيره يقدرونها ب 5 مليون فما
بالنا في ظل هذه الاحداث الكارثيه السودان
حينما يعني تنهار فيه الاوضاع سيكون كما
هو الحال في ليبيا وفي اليمن وفي سوريا
ماوى للجماعات المتشدده والارهابيه يتحول
الى دوله فاشله هذا السيناريو يحدث بالطبع
السيده اسماء انا اشكرك جزيل الشكر من
القاهره انضمت الى ان اسماء الحسين مدير
التحرير صحيفه الاهرام المختصه في الشؤون
الافريقيه
اذا وفي ردود الافعال الدوليه قال مسؤول
بوزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه ان واشنطن تشعر
بقلق عميق ازاء تصاعد العنف في السودان
الذي خلف عشرات الضحايا وبحسب المسؤول قد
تكون استخدمت اسلحه خطيره في الهجمات
الاخيره مؤكدا ان قلق واشنطن الاساسي هو
سلامه المواطنين الامريكيين هناك قبل ذلك
شدد وزير الخارجيه الامريكي انتوني بلينكن
على ضروره انهاء اطراف الاشتباكات الاعمال
القتاليه على الفور دون اي شروط مسبقه هذا
واعربه بريطانيا من جهتي عن اسفها لسقوط
ضحايا في السودان بسبب عمليات العنف
الاخيره مطالبه بوقف العنف بشكل فوري ودعت
الخارجيه البريطانيه في بيان لها قوات
الجيش السوداني والدعم السريع الى وقف
جميع العمليات القتاليه وان تعمل القياده
السودانيه على خفض التصعيد ومنع وقوع مزيد
من الضحايا والعوده الى الحوار لحل
الخلافات
وفي هذه الاثناء فاتت وكاله الانباء
السعوديه انه وزراء خارجيه السعوديه
والامارات والولايات المتحده ناقشوا
الموقف الحالي في السودان خلال اتصال
هاتفي واكد وزراء خارجيه السعوديه
والامارات وامريكا على اهميه وقف التصعيد
العسكري في السودان وضروره العوده الى
الاتفاق الايطالي في السودان
[موسيقى]
من الخرطوم ينضم الينا رئيس التحرير منصه
اخبار وارى محمد شمس الدين سيد محمد مرحبا
بك معي في هذه التقنيه قبل قليل انتشرت
بعض الاخبار في موقع التواصل الاجتماعي
بان هناك وسطات جاريه تتحدث عن اقتراب
اعلان وقفه اطلاق النار في السودان خلال
الساعات القادمه برايك هل هذا متوقع ممكن
مرجح
تحيه طيبه لك اخ نايف وليست المشاهدين الى
ما كانوا يعني هذه الاحاديث احاديث جيده
وايجابيه ونتمنى بطبيعه الحال ان تحدث لكن
الوتيره التي لم تتفاعل معها هذه الاطراف
المعنيه على مدار الايام الماضيه تشيي بان
هذه الوساطه قد تكون كسابقاتها في يعني
عدم نجاحها اذا الامور الميدانيه وصلت الى
مرحله اللا عوده بحسب الكثير من القراءات
الميدانيه والعسكريه
والسياسيه كذلك هذه المرحله التي نحن فيها
الان
يعني قطع فيها السودانيون اشواطا فيما
يتعلق بمساله فقدانهم للثقه في اي من
التحركات التي من الممكن ان يلتزم بها او
تلتزم بها الجهات
التي في معسكر القوى العسكريه بطبيعه
الحال هذا نتيجه
طيب عمليات الوعود
وعدم الالتزام فقط هناك بيان
للقياده العامه للقوات المسلحه للجيش
السوداني يقول نسجل صوت شكر واعرفان
لشعبنا الذي برهن على ولائه وثقته في
القوات المسلحه منذ انطلاق اولى رصاصات
الغدر والخيانه من قبل الميليشيا المتمرده
احتفالات مواطنين بنجاحات القوات المسلحه
تعكس العلاقه الفريده بين المواطن
السوداني وجيش بلاده عمليات اليومين
السابقين ابهرت القيمه العاليه للجندي
السوداني القادر على الصمود والتصدي
بجداره واحترافيه لاكبر مهددات الامن
الوطني السوداني الميليشيا المتمرده
وقيادتها الانتهازيه كانت تتوهم انها
ستكون بديلا للجيش السوداني مكتب الناطق
الرسمي باسم القوات المسلحه
كيف تقرا هذا البيان سيد محمد
هذا بيان يعني حينما نستمع اليه بطبيعه
الحال وكان المعركه قد انتهت هذا بيان
ايجابي هذا بيان بطبيعه الحال لا يختلف
عليه اثنان الجميع يعني يعتبر هذه المؤسسه
من الشعب
وبطبيعه الحال هي جزء من الشعب وابنائه هم
ابناء الشعب السوداني هذا من ناحيه
والخلاف ربما في الفتره الماضيه ما بين
مكونات الشعب السوداني والمؤسسه العسكريه
ليس مع ابناء المؤسسه العسكريه في الرتب
الصغيره او الوسيطه او ماذون الرتب
الرفيعه بل هي مع الرتب العليا في المقام
الاول وهذا ربما ما دفع الطرف الاخر في
قياده الدعم السريع
للذهاب في خيارات يعتقد كان يعتقد منها او
احيى اليه من بعض القوى السياسيه انه
سينجح في الشارع وتلبيه
احد عدم اقتناعهم
بقياده المؤسسه العسكريه ولكن الامر
بطبيعه الحال اي نوع من انواع تغيير ليس
بهذه الطريقه هذه طريقه مرفوضه من الاساس
استخدام الاسلحه وتعريض المدنيين للخطر
وتعريض البلاد كلها للخطر وارتهانها
بطبيعه الحال هذا امر يعني خطير جدا جدا
ويعطل جميع المصالح ويعرقل الحلول
سيضيف تراكمات جديده للعراقيل التي هي
اصلا موجوده ومساله فقدان الثقه الموجوده
ما بين قياده هذه المؤسسه مره اخرى اقول
ابناء الشعب السوداني الكثير من التفاعلات
الايجابيه رصدناها في اليومين في هذين
اليومين ما بين ابناء الشعب السوداني
والعناصر التي تخرج من
رحم هذا الشعب يعني تنصاع وتستجيب لنداء
الواجب بطبيعه الحال وهذا امر مفروغ منه
والجميع كان يتمنى ان تتوحد هذه النص الع
سكريه وان تدمج كل القدرات والامكانات
العسكريه قبل قليل تقول بان هذا البيان
وكان المعركه انتهت لكن السؤال هذه
المعركه باي شكل ستنتهي هل يجب ان تنتهي
بطرف فائز واخر خاسر
هذا سؤال غايه في الاهميه اذ اننا اذا ما
تابعنا التصريحات التي اطلقها سيد جالوب
الامس وفيها نبره التحدي العاليه جدا
والتي يعني يتحدث فيها البرهان ويقول بانه
عليه ان يستسلم
ويصف باوصاف يعني يعني ملؤها يعني
الازدراء انجاز توصيف كذلك ويربطه بعناصر
النظام السابق في بحسب عباراته التي
استخدمها بطبيعه الحال يعني كل هذه تذهب
بنا باتجاه يعني تحليل الموقف وكانه وكان
هذه المعركه لن تتوقف الا بوجود رابح او
او خاسر بحسابات الطرفين بطبيعه الحال
لانه من هذه المعارك لا يوجد رابح فقط
هناك خاسرون وهم ابناء هذا الشعب السوداني
هناك الكثير من حالات الوفيات التي نجمت
عن هذا الرصاص الطائش الذي وهذه العيره
الخطيره التي بالمناسبه نستمع اليها
دقيقه وهي ترتطم ببعض الجدران وهي ايضا
تخترق خزانات المياه وتضررت منها الكثير
من المرافق بالمناسبه كثير من الدانات
سقطت في البيوت روعت الامنين الكثير من
الاطفال دخلوا في حالات او نوبات هستيريا
وهلع من الجراحه الاصوات والاباء لا
يعرفون كيف يصرفون هذه الافكار عن اطفالهم
في هذه الايام بالمناسبه يحاولون اخراجهم
من هذا المشهد باي صور ولكن الامر العصيب
عليهم هناك ايضا الاطفال المحتجزون في
مدرسه كمبوري وهم حوالي 450 طفلا ومعلميهم
وهم مقطوعون بالمناسبه من المياه هناك من
ارشادات من مختلف المنظمات لايصال
علاج والغذاء لهؤلاء الاطفال ولغيرهم من
الموظفين المحتجزين في مؤسسه اخرى ضروره
فتح الممرات الامنه لنقل
محمد شمس الدين ساعود اليك مره اخرى اذا
نشر الجيش السوداني مشاهدينا مقطع فيديو
يظهر
قواته داخل معسكر كرري وهو اكبر قاعده
تابعه لقوات الدعم السريع شمال ام درمان
نشاهد
الله اكبر الله اكبر استلام
معسكر كرري السريع
عربات ام مدرعاتهم
[موسيقى]
نشرت القوات المسلحه السودانيه مقاطع
اظهرت احتفالات الجيش بانتصاره باحد
العمليات العسكريه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
هذا هو اطلق الجيش السوداني سرح اللواء
الصادق سيد بعدما كان اسيرا لدى قوات
الدعم السريع منذ عام 2020
بارك الله سياده الصادق
الحمد لله على السلامه يا اخي ودارينك
الشعب السوداني
الحمد لله على السلامه والله
على كل حال نحمد الله انه يعني
خرجوا عن القانون وتمردوا على
القوات المسلحه وقدرت يعني
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر
الحمد لله
[موسيقى]
بعود مره اخرى الى ضيفي من الخرطوم رئيس
تحرير منصه اخبار وراء محمد شمس الدين
مرحبا بك معي مره اخرى سيد محمد برايك هذه
الاشتباكات هذه الازمه السياسيه العسكريه
بين الطرفين هل اطلقت رصاصه الرحمه على
العمليه السياسيه للانتقاليه في السودان
بشقيها للاتفاق الايطالي والاتفاق الختامي
ايضا
هذا سؤال المرحله نايف في الساحه السياسيه
السودانيه اذا كان المقياس ربما
للاجابه على هذا السؤال بشكل دقيق جدا كان
بعد اندلاع العمليه ربما بساعه او ساعتين
اذا ما كانت هدات الامور فانها فان مساحه
التهدئه والعوده يعني الى المسار الذي رسم
من قبل من اختاروا هذه العمليه السياسيه
التي فصلت بالمناسبه ناقصه عن
مكونات رئيسيه وكبيره في البلاد ونقصه هنا
المكونات التي كانت في ذات معسكر
القوى السياسيه التي وقعت على الاتفاق
الاطاري الا انها اختلفت معها يعني فضلت
ان تنفصل عنها هناك قوه كانت موجوده في
المجلس المركزي بطبيعه الحال وفضلت عدم
المواصله في ذلك المسار اذ ان هذه النتيجه
كانت ربما يعني واضحه لكثير منهم هذا
التصعيد المكتوم الذي كان يحدث بين الفين
والاخرى ما بين قيادات الدعم السريع
وقيادات المؤسسه العسكريه كانت تؤشر الى
هذا المشهد الذي وصلنا اليه يوم امس ونعيش
تبعاته اليوم ايضا بطبيعه الحال فان
حسابات الساسه فيما يتعلق
بالنجاح او انعاش العمليه هذه العمليه
الان تحتضر بمعنى كلمه تحتضر انعاش هذه
العمليه بات امرا صعبا بل مكلفا بل وفي
مهب الريح لماذا لان هناك معطيات جديده
دخلت على الخط
يعني معركه ما زالت لم تحسن بعد ولكن
النتيجه النهائيه منها ستستغل من قبل
اطراف اخرى نعرف بان هناك مكونات تدفع
بطريق يعني قطع الطريق على اي عمليه
سياسيه ليس فقط عبر العمليه السياسيه
المفصله بطريقه
القوى السياسيه في الفتره الماضيه ولكن
نعني هنا القوه الاسلاميه التي تريد افشال
الامر برمته واستعاده زمام الامور باي
طريقه من الطرق هل هذا يعني بان
المستفيد مما يحدث اليوم هي فلول النظام
السابق كما يعني يعتقد بعض السياسيين
والمشاهدين
والمراقبين عفوا للمشهد السوداني
هذا صحيح هناك الكثير من المراقبين يقولون
بانه الرابح الاكبر من هذه العمليات ربما
في المقام الاول هي مختلف مكونات الحركات
او الجماعات الاسلاميه التي انتمت الى
الحركه الاسلاميه والحركه الاسلاميه
برمتها والتي غيرت جلدها وتوزعت في سلال
كثيره في الفتره الماضيه لتحاول تقديم
نفسها مره جديده حينما حدث ذلك الضغط على
من قاموا بتوقيع الاتفاق الاطاري من
شركائهم في الفتره الانتقاليه ما بعد 2019
وحدث الشقاق دخل الاسلاميون على الخط
ليحاولوا القول بانهم كذلك جزء من المشهد
وانهم لابد وان يشتركوا وما الى ذلك على
الرغم انهم كانوا يديرون الفتره الماضيه
ورفضهم الشعب السوداني الى انه ما زالوا
يصرون بشتى السبل وهذه المره عبر قياداتهم
التقليديه يعني يقومون بتمويل الكثير من
الانشطه
وقد شاهدنا في رمضان هذا فقط العديد من
الافطارات التي مولت عبر قياده هذه الحركه
وهي تحاول بشتى السبل ان تدخل على الخط
الان وتفرض موقعا جديدا نتمنى بطبيعه
الحال ان تنتهي الامور
بالمؤسسه العسكريه وهي في موقع جيد وقد
استغلت هذا الموقع لصالحها لارضاء جميع
الاطراف نعم هذا المكون
بين قوسين الاسلاموي في السودان هو جزء من
هذا الشعب ولابد من ارضائه بصوره من الصور
حتى لا يعتاد او يرجع الى الاساليب التي
تبعها في الفترات الماضيه كما يقول الكثير
من المراقبين وبالتالي سيضع العراقيل
والعصي في عجلات التقدم نحو الفتره
الانتقاليه التي يرجوها السودانيون جميعا
ومن الناحيه الاخرى يرضي بقيه اطراف
المجتمع السوداني التي تنظر اليه بصوره
ايجابيه شكرا جزيلا لك من الخرطوم محمد
شمس الدين رئيس تحرير منصه اخبار
اذا تتوالى الادانات الدوليه لاحداث
السودان فيما يخص الاشتباكات الدائره بين
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع حيث
ادان السفير الروسي في الخرطوم رفض الجيش
السوداني التفاوض مع الدعم السريع اما
السفير الامريكي في السودان فقال ان اعضاء
مجلس الامن يطالبون بوقف اطلاق النار
واعاده الهدوء فورا بينما عبرت الخارجيه
الامريكيه عن قلقها حياله مستويات العنف
التي شهدتها السودان الخارجيه البريطانيه
دعت كلا الطرفين الجيش السوداني والدعم
السريع الى وقف العمليات القتاليه والعنف
الدائر في السودان
هذا هو تهمت قوه الحريه والتغيير في
السودان ما سمتها بفلوول النظام السابق
باشعال فتيل الازمه والتعبئه للحرب وادعت
قوى الحريه والتغيير في بيان النشره عبر
فيسبوك قيادتي الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع
لوقف المواجهات العسكريه فورا والعوده
لطاوله التفاوض محذره من تهديد وحده
وتماسك وسياده البلاد كما دعت الشعب
السوداني للتصدي لمخططات ما اسمتها بفلوول
نظام المؤتمر الوطني البائد وعدم السماح
بتمريرها تحت اي غطاء كان واعتزال خطابات
الكراهيه
والتهييج وتهجيج الحرب
هذا وقت تتواصل الاشتباكات في محيط
القياده العامه للجيش بالعاصمه الخرطوم
كما نشاهد امامنا في هذه الصوره هذا المقر
مقر القياده العامه يقع في المنطقه
الشماليه من العاصمه على بعد نحو اربعه
كيلومترات فقط من مطار الخرطوم كما انه
يعد مركزا مهما وحساسا بالنسبه لقوات
الجيش السوداني ويستمر اطلاق الرصاص في
محيط المبنى مع تداول اخبار عن استخدام
اسلحه ثقيله
اذا كما نتابع واياكم في شريط الاخبار
العاجله اسفل الشاشه المبعوثه الاممي
للسودان يدعو لانهاء اعمال العنف اذا
البعثه الامميه
بالسودان تقول بان اعمال العنف المتكرره
تقل بتوزيع
المساعدات الدعوات لانهاء اعمال العنف
ايضا كانت قد عبرت عنها مصر وجنوب السودان
عبر
بيان مشترك اذا المبعوث الاممي للسوداني
ودين الهجوم على موظفي الامم المتحده في
دارفور الان في هذا الخبر العاجل المبعوث
الاممي للسوداني ودين الهجوم على موظفي
الامم المتحده في دارفور دعا ايضا قبل
قليل لانهاء اعمال العنف اكد ايضا بان هذه
الاعمال
المتكرره تقل بتوزيع المساعدات اذا
المبعوث الاممي للسوداني يؤكد بان هناك
هجوم على موظفي الامم المتحده في دارفور
ادان هذا
الهجوم كما نشاهد دعا ايضا
لوقف فوري
لاطلاق النار في السودان
وشدد ايضا على
في تصريحاته على ان اعمال العنف المتكرره
تقل بتوزيع
المساعدات كما نتابع في هذا
الخبر العاجل ايضا اكد على وجود هجوم على
موظفي الامم المتحده في دارفور ادان هذا
الهجوم على موظفي الامم المتحده في دارفور
المبعوث الاممي الى السودان في هذه
الاخبار
العاجله اسفل الشاشه
المبعوث الاممي لدى السودان فولكر بيريتس
اذا ناشدت اداره وزاره الصحه بولايه
الخرطوم كافه الاطراف المتنازعه في البلاد
السماحه بمرور عربات الاسعاف لنقل
المصابين من المدنيين والعسكريين وعدم
استهداف الاطقم الطبيه وقالت الاداره ان
المواثيق الدوليه ومعاهدات حقوق الانسان
تنص على توفير ممرات امنه اثناء الحرب
محدره من ان نفاد الامدادات الطبيه
للمستشفيات وعدم القدره للوصول اليها يهدد
بانهيار النظام الصحي بالكامل وعدم القدره
على تقديم الخدمه
اذا مشاهدينا كما نتابع في الخبر العاجل
اسفل الشاشه الاشتباكات مستمره في محيط
سجن كوبر حيث يوجد الرئيس المخلوع عمر
البشير اذا الاشتباكات تستمر في محيط سجن
كوبر كما ذكرنا حيث يوجد الرئيس المخلوع
عمر
البشير ولا زنا نتابع هذه الصور
للاشتباكات
وطبعا رشقات الرصاص الموجوده بالقرب من
محيط مقر قياده الجيش السوداني في هذه
الصور الخاصه
بالعربيه كما نتابع واياكم الان على شاشه
العربيه اذا استمرار الاشتباكات في محيط
سجن كوبر حيث يوجد رئيس المخلوع عمر
البشير
شيء مؤسف اللي عم يصير بالسودان بس يعني
بالمجمل نحن اكيد مع كل شيء اسمه شرعيه
ومع الجيش ودود اي انقلاب اي دوله عربيه
حرام اي دوله عربيه يصير فيها
الشعب السوداني الشعب معطر الحرام اللي عم
يصير فيها هيك السودان بلاك بلد شقيق بلد
عربي واللي بيحصل ده طبعا صعب جدا وفي
مشكله بوجه كلمه للشعب السوداني ان هم
يصمدوا ويكونوا ايد واحده مع بعضيهم لان
اللي بيحصل دون بيفرج العالم كله عليهم
التكالب على السلطه وفرض الراي مش هيوصل
السودان الا في الحديد وبلاش موضوع
الانقلابات والحاجات الديه لان دي عماله
تضيع في وقت كبير جدا وبتستهلك ثروات
السودان واقتصاد السودان
اذا وزاره الصحه مشاهدينا الكرام
تناشد اطراف النزاع
بالسماح بنقل المصابين جراء
الاشتباكات التي لا تزال دائره ولا تتوقف
في عدد من المدن والولايات السودانيه
وهذه الصوره المباشره التي نتابعها واياكم
من العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم تحديدا من
محيط مقر قياده
القوات المسلحه السودانيه هذه الساعه
انتهت من تغطيتنا لكن التغطيه لا تزال
مستمره مع الزميل طالب كنعان اليكت
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات